عقب تمرد فاشل في موسكو مساعي لا يبدو
انها قد اقتربت من نهايتها فهو مصمم على
تدارك الموقف بخطوات تبقي مجموعته على قيد
الحياه تعليق التجنيد في مراكز التوظيف
الاقليميه التابعه لفاجنر لمده شهر ونقل
كل العمليات الى بيلاروسيا هي من بين ابرز
اولويات بريكوجين في المرحله المقبله وفق
ما تناولته قناته الخاصه على التليجرام
غير ان صحيفه لوفيغاغو الفرنسيه اشارت الى
انفاكنرت توصل عمليات تجنيد المتطوعين في
روسيا بصفه عاديه وتحت اعين السلطات ما
يعني ان نهايه المجموعه في روسيا لم يحن
وقتها بعد وفق مراقبين فعلى الرغم من
عمليه التمرد الفشله لا يزال على موفاجنر
مرفوعا في العديد من المباني الموجوده في
نوفاسيبي وسماره ومورمان مكاتب المجموعه
مفتوحه ولا تزال تسجل مقاتلين جدد للقتال
في اوكرانيا في نوفا ثالثي اكبر مدن روسيا
تم تعليق ملصقات اعلانيه مره اخرى عندما
مدخل مركز تجنيد فاجنر بعد ان تمت ازالتها
خلال التمرد حيث ان الاعضاء الجدد يوقعون
عقودا مع مجموعه تيفاجنر وليس وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وفق لوكيغو هذا التجنيد
يتعارض مع خطه روسيه نقلتها
في تفكيك امبراطوريه فاجنر لصالحه ما يشير
الى ان عمليه التفكيك لن تكون سهله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات